the joe rogan experience
this is as good as spot as i need to
talk about this um we i want to make
sure i clarify something because
there was some there was an operation
this is a guy who was a
billionaire diamond guy who uh wound up
getting a
dick enlargement operation and he died
because the anesthesia
and he was in another country and we
pulled out we
we were saying somehow or another it got
connected to this company that does that
in the united states
it had nothing phenomenal yeah the
article i had said like
he was getting a similar surgery and
that this one
the one only the pneuma only happens in
the u.s but he was getting something
done in europe so it was like
different well they reached out to me to
explain first of all
the guy died from anesthesia you can get
in you could die from anesthesia from
any operation that nothing to do with
the
the penis enlargement operation to use
more correct term dick enlargement
uh but he didn't die from that and
that's just as safe as uh
getting your nose fixed or getting your
knee meniscus operated on right it's
just the
any surgery where you have uh anesthesia
carries a certain amount of risk but
apparently this
dick thing works they actually can
grow your dick bigger now well if you're
risking your life
well you're risking your life if you go
to the dentist yeah i don't put you
under
like any time you get put under right if
you if you if you anything you're doing
with anesthesia there's a very small
chance that something could go wrong but
it had nothing to do with this
dick operation so i just wanted to make
sure that people know that if you
look this up i don't want anything any
uh
incorrect assumptions to be out there
and i carry no ill will towards us
these people that make this and
apparently it works so i just want
everybody to know that yeah it carry no
ill will towards this company that makes
dicks bigger
apparently it actually it's a weird
thing right like uh
for a man to do that there's certain
taboos
that are involved in even admitting
that you have an issue like a little
dick is a weird thing right because it's
one of the
rare things that's unfortunate that you
can make fun of
right like you can't make fun of a
little person right like if you make fun
of a person who's this uh you know
you're not supposed to call them midgets
right right supposed to call them little
people
right you make fun of a person who's a
dwarf or a little person
you're a cruel person right but if you
make fun of a guy with a little dick
like he deserves it sometimes he
deserves it or some [ __ ]
that's a weird thing that women are
allowed to do
like you're allowed to make fun of dudes
having little decks we should
there should be something in the same
vein yes
to protect the world
from cruelty right because if you have a
little [ __ ] that's fantastic
everybody's excited about it isn't that
crazy what a weird situation
but a big dick is a sign of a reality
right so we we salute you panuma
that's the name of the company we salute
you for helping men achieve larger dicks
yeah
[Applause]